hello this is choices how can i help you
the phone rarely stops ringing at this
abortion clinic in memphis which serves
some of the poorest women in america
okay so let me go ahead and
reschedule your appointment
abortion rights are under attack
particularly in the south women travel
here from hundreds of miles away from
states where terminating pregnancy is
increasingly restrictive
are you 100 sure you want to have an
abortion i am okay and is anyone forcing
or making you no okay wonderful
joy is preparing a patient but this
clinic too may soon be forced to turn
women away tomorrow the supreme court is
hearing a direct challenge to a ruling
which legalized abortion nationwide in
1973. for the first time in 50 years the
right to abortion could be ripped up
it's a lot you know it's a lot for us to
continue to be able to provide people
with
uh
safe
access to abortion
that's the key that really is the key
clinical services director nikia fears
for the future
we know that abortion
being becoming illegal will not stop
abortion people who don't want to be
pregnant will work really hard not to be
pregnant and so our fear is that people
will do
things that are more harmful to
themselves
and that we will go back to seeing more
women end up dying because they don't
want to be pregnant across the state
border is the battleground in this case
mississippi wants to ban abortion from
15 weeks far earlier than a fetus could
survive outside the womb
this pink house is a beacon for many the
last remaining abortion clinic in a
state of three million people
young lady that baby is a gift what can
we do to help you patients here must
clear a gauntlet of anti-abortion
activists if your baby is alive your
baby
deserves a mama to love it and protect
it
this fence was erected to keep them out
but they scream abuse anyway
even blasting religious music through
the speakers
[Music]
patricia fights to be heard above the
noise
23 years
23 years i've lived here
and 23 years these folks have been out
here
as a teenager before abortion was
legalized she had a back alley procedure
i was at this woman's house and she had
me lay on a table
like a wooden table dining room type
table
no anesthesia
and so you know so the procedure itself
was painful
that's a humiliating hurtful experience
and
so i don't want anybody to have to go
through that
[Applause]
for the second time in half a century
nine supreme court justices will between
them decide the future rights of
millions of women the years have
advanced but for many it feels america
is going back in time martha kellner sky
news mississippi